so i've had this
in the uh on deck for a few days now i
got to finally mention it you've
probably heard about it by now this is
from the daily wire the most successful
female quote unquote ever to appear on
jeopardy is actually a biological male
amy schneider the show's first
transgender contestant became the
highest earning contestant who
identifies as female after winning for
the 18th consecutive time last friday
um i guess his winnings are probably
higher now but schneider has now won 706
000 on the game show with a chance to
win more tonight
um
yeah so there's a few days old i'm not
sure if amy schneider is still kicking
ass on jeopardy or not but the the
highest earning woman
in jeopardy history is a man
here's a good morning america a few days
ago gushing over this whole story
we're going to turn to a story that's a
little bit more uplifting hopefully uh
jeopardy champion amy schneider in a
league of her own now this morning she
won for the 21st straight time on
wednesday the most by a woman just days
after taking the record for highest
all-time earnings for a woman earlier
this year this year schneider she made
history as the first transgender
contestant to make the tournament of
champions she still has a long way to go
though to catch host ken jennings and
his 74-game winning streak but it has
been fun to watch she's well on her way
who run the world
girls
there you go
do they though because
the top female jeopardy contestant is a
man
and the top female college swimmer is a
man
and the first
female
four-star admiral in the public health
service is a man
and some of the top female mma
fighters have been men
and some of the top female track high
school track athletes have all been men
so do girls run the world
girls don't even run
female track anymore
um
if if if this
if it wasn't for the fact that our
civilization was uh was being was being
fundamentally deconstructed you would
have to you would have to laugh about
this because the patriarchy has won
you know the patriarchy was it was on
the ropes a little bit for a few decades
really
and uh and then and then they they kind
of you know
regrouped and and thought about it
and then realized
that no if the patriarch is going to win
it has to be has to be this has to be
infiltration the patriarchy has
infiltrated the female ranks
and achieved ultimate victory it's kind
of inspiring
in a certain way
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends